Được miếng kêu hàng ngoa nước ngoài lợi giụ Việt Nam làm điểm chung chuyển đến nay thủy,
đặc biệt sò khi Mỹ át thủy đổi ứng bố mệt sáo phần chăm với hàng nhà tử Việt Nam.
Các các quan chức năng đăng trình khai hàng lật biệt phát nhằm bảo vệ lý tiến thương nghiệm
giữa mết ín Việt Nam và giữ chỉ quan hệ thương ngoài với Mỹ.
Ngành hải quan đã tăng cường thành tra, kìm tra sau thông quan về sức xử hàng ngoa,
ra sát sân nghiệp có kinh gạy xuất nhập khẩu tăng bất thường xò với năng lực.
Kìm sát chặt quyền liệu nghiệp khẩu và quy chính sản xuất nhằm phát hiện hàng vi giả lận xuất xử.
Nếu vụ giảm mạo nhắn hiệu, vi nhá sản xuất tại Việt Nam khi chưa đủ tư chi đã bị sử li nhiêm.
Bình năm và Mỹ đã tăng cường phối hợp qua câu chế cho đổi xử liệu định từ,
chia sẻ thông tin và sáng kiến anh ninh công tin lời.
Chỉ phủ cũng định hướng sẵn lọc các sự án đầu tư nước ngoài tiêm ẩm dùi gió chuyển tại bất hợp pháp.
Các chuyên giá quyền cao xe nghiệp Việt Nam cần chù đậu kìm xuất chối cùng ứng,
đẩn thương mại. Đây là dài pháp cảnh cơ giúp hàng viết cũng vàng trước biến động thời quan tòn cầu.